I want to do a quick video on something
that you're likely to see in a
statistics class and that's the notion
of a type 1 error type type 1 type 1
error and all this error means is that
you've rejected this is the error of
rejecting let me just in a different
color rejecting rejecting the null
hypothesis even though it is true even
though it is true so for example and a
lot of the and actually all of the
hypothesis testing examples we've seen
we start assuming that the null
hypothesis is true we assume we always
assume that the null hypothesis is true
and given that the null hypothesis is
true we say ok if the null hypothesis is
true then the mean is usually going to
be equal to some value so we create some
distribution assuming that the null
hypothesis is true it normally has some
mean value right over there and then we
have some sent we have some statistic we
have some statistic and we are seeing if
the null hypothesis is true what is the
probability of getting that statistic or
getting a result that extreme or more
extreme then that's that statistic so
let's say that the statistic gives us
some value over here and we say gee you
know what
there's only it there's only I don't
know there might be a 1% chance there's
only a 1% probability there's only a 1%
probability of getting a result that
that extreme or greater and then with if
that's I guess low enough of a threshold
force we will reject we will reject the
null hypothesis so in this case in this
case we will so let's say let's say that
actually let's think of it this way
let's say that 1% is our threshold we
say look we're going to assume that the
null hypothesis is true there's some
threshold that if we get and if we get a
value any more extreme than that value
there's less than a 1% chance of that
happening so let's say we're looking at
sample means and we get a sample mean
that is way out here we say well there's
less than a 1
cent chance of that happening given that
the given that the null hypothesis is
true so we are going to reject the null
hypothesis so we will reject the null
hypothesis now what does that mean
though let's say that this area the
probability of getting a result like
that or that or that much more extreme
is just this area right here so that's
let's say that's half a percent or maybe
I can write it this way let's say it's
half a percent and because it's so
unlikely to get a statistic like that
given assuming that the null hypothesis
is true we decide to reject the null
hypothesis or another way to view it is
there's a point five percent chance that
we have made a type 1 error in rejecting
the null hypothesis because if the null
hypothesis is true there's a point five
percent chance that this is that that
this could still happen so in rejecting
it we would make mistake there's a point
five percent chance we've made a type 1
error I just want to clear that up
hopefully they clarified it for you it's
sometimes a little bit confusing but
we're going to use what we learn in this
video and the previous video to now
tackle an actual example